hi my name is Shana I have three cats
and two dogs I love all of my pets
eerily their my little gems so I'm
always trying to figure out ways to
include them in my daily activities
recently I found a dog seat that fits in
between yourself and the handlebars of a
bike I got really excited I have a corgi
and she is right within the weight range
for a doggie seat like that
so I'm gonna find out if my Corgi pixel
will enjoy riding a bike with me and I
hope she does we have the instructions
here the actual seat and that's the know
these little helpers to help her to lift
up the seat with this tool and I
it's like lefty-loosey day yeah it's
lefty-loosey
how do you feel
[Music]
I wasn't really sure if she would
actually take to this dog seat because
she's you know she's very particular
about the things she likes and the
things she doesn't like they started out
by just putting her in the seat and
walking her back and forth down the
street after this shield-like refused to
walk probably anywhere she got a kick
out of it she was smiling the entire
time I was absolutely surprised she's
like I'm ready for my movie moment
the time finally came for our epic bike
ride
[Music]
I was of course a little bit nervous
because I had never driven her on my
bike
so got ready we slowly started
[Music]
and the rest was history pixel loved it
[Applause]
I'm so happy I bought this for us and I
cannot wait for us to do more rides
together in the future
[Music]
you